[Music]
when I was younger every Christmas Eve
was a pretty exciting time for me I mean
Christmas of course I was very excited
for but my next-door neighbors would
have a party and they would have Grand
Theft Auto set up for whoever wanted to
play it now I was pretty young at the
time and Grand Theft Auto was an 18 so
my mom wouldn't allow me to play who
thought the games she was trying to
shelter me from the hideous reality of
video game and I mean it makes sense GTA
is full of drugs foul language and you
know prostitution is my huh but she
allowed me on the Christmas Eves to play
as long as she was watching me and as
long as I didn't do any missions and I
drove around like a good citizen
stopping at red lights and everything
and believe it or not I still had very
fond memories about playing GTA even
though I never did any of the missions I
just really wanted to get a nice bike
and I was proud that I was really good
at stopping at red lights this is
because games are so much more than just
that they've been a massive part of my
life for the longest time they told me
maths when textbooks left me bored and
extremely confused
[Music]
they help you bond with my dad over his
love of racing cars we competitively
played Colin McRae but best of all these
video games offered me new worlds to
escape to when the world around me
became really difficult to understand
and it offered me new characters to form
bonds with who actually really helped me
when I was going through some really
hard times and I felt like I couldn't
talk to anyone in my real life hurry
back I'm going to miss you and now that
motor I mean not much has changed I'm
still playing video games I am still
super excited for Animal Crossing with
his love of them massive childhood game
of mine I even keep in contact with old
friends through playing video games with
them when it's difficult to stay in
touch with them otherwise after we've
all kind of left school and education
and moved on our own paths
I even freaking work in the games
industry so yeah
video games have always been a massive
part of my life and they have been such
a positive influence on who I am today
but I know that I'm not the only one
that feels this strongly about video
games
so I went to insomnia to find out why
other people love games and how it has
impacted their own life questions out
question down I'm still recording by the
way so I guess it's time for me to get a
question job three words
imagine
[Music]
escape enjoyment and
community community connection
interactive entertainment challenge
stories I'd like to take this
opportunity to apologize personally to
anyone who I may have made to feel
slightly uncomfortable with my good
questions and responses anyway back to
the questions so why do people play
games it's a medium in which I guess
it's like just fun to watch a movie for
me but you actually get to be a part of
that experience I don't think that's
something that you kind of grow out of
you can do whatever you want whatever
you want
yes Barney over 10 years ago streets pay
for weekend I was like 15 at a time I
joined the server and these guys like
super nice so I immediately like faith
to the server and purchased you have
always done that server we played in the
team together
I stopped yourself and a bunch of the
other members of our team continues yes
a lot of them went on to be confessional
overwatch yes we are connected through a
lot of video games I always say
do you think about the current virtual
reality so games can help beautiful
friendships be formed apparently they
can also be a great source of
entertainment but what makes a game more
than just a game what makes a game worth
investing time it's more than just it's
about having a something in the game
that means that I'm invested because my
actions will have a knock-on effect on
something or someone else another
character died the first game I think I
ever felt was Star Wars I suppose the
biggest one obviously is beyond Knievel
Tomb Raider that I played at the age of
I think lost five and I think it was
Tomb Raider 2 that I played and I was my
young kind of moving part of my growing
up for me
you're just the general so this story of
the game characters different well I
guess I just looked the fact that that
world kind of invited me to be a part of
it to kind of take part literally in the
story and world so I was happening
within that universe it was just so
amazing to me you know all those fast
levels that like the word I think you
could be visiting for me back then it
was basically an open word game which is
call open working now but it was so
amazing because it was so immersive it
was the first PC to be had and we had a
flight stick and the game is about
flying X wings and whatever around doing
Star Wars missions and all the ones from
the films and it was it was like flying
a next week it was it was awesome it was
so so much that well seems really
positive but what a gamers view on
violence in video games I mean there are
a lot of games where shooting is a main
mechanic so can that actually seep out
and cause violence in the real world
even if it is correlated I mean there
are so many video games that have
nothing to do with violence and there's
so many violent video games that have no
interest in real violence it had no
relation at all do what people do if
anything keep me how people it can't sit
down it's not you know a translation of
something that you actually want to do
real life it's just kind of you know a
moment to kind of switch your brain
enough and get involved of these
characters because that's what those
characters would do something you would
do it's what they would do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much for just giving us
these insights to two new worlds and two
different people the different ways of
thinking are actually broadening our
minds and our opinions so I think that's
really important I think that's one of
the graces again it was really to be
able to experience so she is everybody
did that person foremost I would like to
say good job because like you did
something truly amazing I might be
speaking to a particular developer in my
mind but that goes to all the developer
out there you did a great job you made
that colossal job in shipping such an
ambitious project because no matter what
game you're working on it is it involves
a lot of work which sometimes don't
doesn't really go appreciate it as it
should so well good job and like keep on
doing what you're doing if you love
[Applause]
chanting go down good job creating a
world that has so many consequences as
though there's just so much to it you
could play the same game a thousand
times and it would be different every
single time also money it was just
awesome to hear why people love video
games and even though there are so many
different types of video games out there
with different genres it was so lovely
to see the friendships that have been
made and the excitement and the
happiness that it brings to so many
people at the end of the day it's an art
form
it's another entertainment platform but
because of the interactivity that it
provides it's so much more so yeah maybe
every now and then video games might be
seen as something negative it allows
people to explore a whole new way of
living it allows people to become a hero
a villain a pirate a whale a llama
probably I'm just trying to see if I can
find a game by a llama I'm sure you can
be a lover in a game but the point is is
that that's not who you are in real life
and sure maybe it might spare some
people on in some way or another just
like films can this horror films as gory
film but at the end of the day it brings
so much more positivity than negativity
and I just wanted to make this video
this cheesy ass video to represent my
love of video games and what it sports
me and also just celebrate how it's
changed the lives of so many others as
well
so anyway I would love to hear why you
love gaming what you love about it
what's your favorite game or your
favorite moments please write it in the
comments it would make me just really
happy to read about it thank you for
watching and have an increase between if
your is friend
[Music]
[Music]